[Music]
breaking news this Tuesday Donald Trump
indicted again the new charges against
the former American president and what
it means for his bid to win back the
White House firefighters Without Borders
hopefully this is an agreement that
stays forever
is with the American and Mexican Crews
helping Canadians fight wildfires
Canada's bold new way to get smokers to
butt out a warning on every cigarette
can't be missed the other addiction the
government is being urged to crack down
on next and forget flying cars how about
an underwater one good luck fellow the
deep sea Drive hoping for a route into
the record books
foreign
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with breaking news former U.S
president Donald Trump has been indicted
by a Federal grand jury part of special
counsel Jack Smith's investigation into
Trump's efforts to overturn the results
of the 2020 presidential election and
attempting to prevent the peaceful
transfer of power to Joe Biden Jackson
prosco is following this Jackson do we
know what's in this indictment hi Donna
the charges include conspiracy to
defraud the United States conspiracy to
obstruct an official proceeding and
conspiracy against rights the 45-page
long indictment also mentions six
co-conspirators although they aren't
named at this point essentially the
allegation here is of a widespread
campaign to knowingly spread lies about
the election results than use those lies
to deploy fakes slates of electors to
pressure State officials to ignore the
will of Voters and to use the justice
department to try and run sham
investigations into the election
ultimately that effort culminated with a
plot to enlist the vice president based
on those lies in that ultimately failed
effort to overturn the results on
January 6th which as we know turned
violent the attack on our nation's
capital on January 6 2021
was an unprecedented assault on the seat
of American democracy
it's described in the indictment it was
fueled by lies
Lies by the defendant
targeted at obstructing a Bedrock
function of the U.S government
Jackson Trump has already called this
indictment fake before it even came out
he's been indicted before of course he's
still running for president in 2024.
will this make any difference well you
know he's expected to make his first
court appearance on Thursday and will
likely use that to actually build on his
base of support some polling out just in
the past couple days here shows that he
is almost 40 percentage points ahead of
his closest Republican rival when it
comes to fighting for the party's
presidential nomination and Donna this
one is remarkable in a head-to-head
hypothetical matchup against Joe Biden
both men are tied at 43 support despite
all his legal troubles he is on path to
potentially becoming president once
again in 24.
long way to go till that election
Jackson Frasco in Washington thanks
August is off to a hot and dangerous
start and many Canadians are on edge
about wildfires more than a thousand
fires are burning across this country
646 are out of control this summer has
already been the worst Fire season in
Canada and it's not over to help the
federal government has called in more
than 2 000 firefighters from multiple
countries
[Applause]
you remember this group they are from
South Africa they landed in Edmonton
back in June a welcome show of
international solidarity to relieve
exhausted local crews in BC the
government has requested 1 000
International firefighters Crews from
Australia Brazil Mexico and the U.S are
already there many taking on one of BC's
largest fires near Kamloops our nitu
garcha got exclusive access to some of
them working the front lines nitu
Donna we heard from some of these
firefighters behind me who are from the
U.S and Mexico and they highlight how
they're picking up on new knowledge to
take back home for their wildfires and
also how they bring with them unique
techniques to BC and we got an inside
look at some of them
specialty is getting water to an
incident and and plumbing that incident
with hose California firefighter Michael
Piper's first time in Canada is with his
five-person engine crew
bringing with them several 600 gallon
fire trucks from the Golden State which
is experiencing its slowest start to the
season in decades weirdly enough we had
a wet winter finally not a drought and
so it's prolonged the season so it
allowed us the opportunity to come up
here it's a once in a lifetime
opportunity for us and we're super
excited to be here we are honored to be
here it's amazing uh some of the first
engines strike teams that can just drive
through the border and come assist on
this and hopefully this is an agreement
that stays like forever
their support on the Ross Moore fire
about 10 kilometers south of the city of
Kamloops helps relieve exhausted local
Crews The Blaze is among the largest in
BC burning near a big urban center BC
Wildfire service officials say this
controlled burn began with a technique
first introduced in this province by
Mexican firefighters using a machete to
keep the Flames out of the tree canopy
it's a key and special weapon used
against the wildfires according to
Jessica Espinosa speaking through a
translator
what she's particularly proud of is the
use of the machete which is a
traditional firefighting tool that the
Mexicans use back home
two Griffin helicopters and 17 military
members from Alberta have also arrived
to support BC Crews until you see it
from the area you don't really get an
appreciation for just how rugged the
terrain is out here we're really being
put to the test with climate experts
predicting even more severe Wildfire
Seasons more often these foreign Crews
say working together like this is more
important than ever
the biggest concern now is hot dry and
windy conditions forecast over the
coming days which are expected to
increase the fire Behavior here Donna
okay need to near a Kamloops BC tonight
thanks further south NBC there's some
relief for people in the popular tourist
town versus a change in the wind
direction has helped Crews there working
to contain a fast-moving fire and
hundreds of people have been able to
return to their homes Heather urich's
West is in osuyus where everyone is
keeping an eye on those winds Heather
Donna the Eagle Bluff Wildfire has grown
considerably from 1400 to More Than 3
000 hectares in the last 24 hours while
most of that growth has been on the side
opposite of Asus some of that growth has
been towards the town as well still the
immediate fire danger has decreased
enough that most of those who were
forced from their communities have been
able to return to their homes
things are back on par at the osuyu's
golf club but at the end of this driving
range you can see just how close this
neighborhood came to disaster very scary
I guess if the wind had been more
powerful or something along those lines
and it started to catch the odd house
could have been very bad welcome home
hundreds of residents were allowed to
return home Monday afternoon though by
later that day flare-ups on the hillside
made clear why an evacuation alert was
still in place we've got everything
packed all we have to do is load it in
the vehicle and head out again and we've
got the reservation at the hotel the
most evacuation orders and a number of
alerts have been rescinded the Eagle
Bluff fire grows nearly doubling its
size since Monday a majority of the
activity that we have been seeing is
along the west flank and the northwest
corner of the Wildfire so that's due to
the winds that we're seeing in the area
and the fuel types it means fire crews
are gearing up for a lengthy fight
tonight
in a show of appreciation local business
owners have been working around the
clock to keep the many fighting this
Blaze well fed before we knew it our
wonderful Community started sending
money and e-transfers and cash donations
and salads and it kind of just exploded
from there within less than 24 hours
we've raised about seven thousand
dollars we've been cooking non-stop
several businesses remain under an
evacuation order as the hill above them
continues to burn fire Crews remain in
the area building fire breaks with
support of six helicopters a reminder
that this fire is still very much a
threat Donna all right Heather urich's
Western osuyu specie thanks that
stifling heat in Phoenix Arizona has
finally eased a little it was down to 42
degrees on Monday and that was just
enough to end the city's
record-shattering streak of 31 straight
days of temperatures at or above 43
degrees more extreme heat is expected to
return tomorrow though the average
temperature in Phoenix in July was a
blistering 39 degrees the hottest months
ever in an American city
in Australia police have charged a
former child care worker with hundreds
of sex crimes against children the
details are disturbing and police
acknowledge the details will be deeply
distressing for the families of the
children
today I can outline the details of
operation Tenterfield an investigation
that has led to a former child care
worker being charged with
1623 child abuse offenses against 91
children
including 136 counts of rape and 110
counts of sexual intercourse with a
child under 10.
investigators allege the 45-year-old
recorded the offenses on phones and
cameras over a 15-year period while
working at a dozen child care centers in
Sydney Brisbane and overseas he has been
in custody since August of last year
it's beyond the Realms of anyone's
imagination what this person did to
these children
I can only say that you know you try not
to be shocked after a long period of
time in the place and in crime reporting
but this is a horrific horrific case
the 87 Australian children who were
allegedly abused some of whom are now
adults have been identified their
families contacted investigators are
still trying to identify four other
children the most serious charges
carrying a maximum sentence of life in
prison
Canada is recognizing emancipation day
today marking the end of slavery
it is important that while remembering
the sus the suffering of displanted
Africans that we also recognize and
remember that at the same time people
indigenous to these lands were growing
through similar atrocities
August 1st marks the day in 1834 when
the slavery abolition act came into
effect across the British Empire laying
the groundwork to free about eight
hundred thousand enslaved Africans
across the British colonies including in
Canada the transatlantic slave trade
caused the deaths of millions of African
people and their descendants
meta has begun removing access to news
content for Canadian users of Facebook
and Instagram meta had signaled it would
do this after the federal government
passed its online news act in June that
act compels both meta and Google to come
up with Revenue sharing deals with
Publishers for use of their news content
Google is also threatening to remove
news links for all users in Canada by
the end of this year
a new effort to help people butt out
coming up Canada's new anti-smoking
campaign unlike anything done before
a new anti-smoking measure kicked in
today and it's a first for Canada and
the world every individual cigarette not
just the packaging will carry a health
warning printed directly on it the
government says the new regulations will
make it virtually impossible to avoid
the health warnings though as Toria isri
reports the popularity of vaping means
it's time for a shift in strategy
poison in every Puff the risks of
smoking will be underlined on individual
cigarettes tobacco smoke harms children
cigarettes cause leukemia
it's part of a first of its kind
anti-smoking campaign in the world I
think the warning labels are more
educational
tobacco use claims almost 50 000 lives a
year and costs the Canadian Health Care
System 16 billion dollars annually
everything is a good idea as whatever we
do to fight the Beast of tobacco Canada
has been a world leader in that fight
since the 1960s and the first to require
warning labels on packages back in the
1980s the hope today is that no warning
will be overlooked it'll be there when
kids experiment By quote-unquote Boring
a cigarette from a friend they may not
see the package but they're going to see
that warning on every cigarette some
smokers don't think it will work I I'm
going to come out for my five minutes of
peace and quiet from work and have my
smoke I'm not going to read it is
it I guess it's not gonna stop me
around 10 percent of Canadians smoke the
government wants to cut that number in
half by 2035. warnings help but
respirologists say they're not enough
which we could do as a community as a
society is making the nicodine
replacement therapy available for free
for everybody while doctors want more
support to help people quit they also
want more done to stop teenagers from
getting hooked on something else very
few young people are starting to smoke
great you know we've done well with that
on the other hand we've managed to get a
whole new generation of young people
addicted to nicotine vaping Health
Canada introduced new regulations on
vaping last month requiring businesses
to submit ingredient lists but with so
many of the long-term effects unknown
Public Health experts want those risks
spelled out more clearly as well
teria israe Global News Ottawa
a Ukrainian hospital is bombed with
deadly consequences what we've learned
about the victim coming up
in Western India Rescuers are searching
for survivors trapped after a crane
collapsed at a highway construction site
at least 16 workers are known to have
died a number of others were injured the
crane was being used to build a massive
Bridge 80 kilometers from Mumbai
in Ukraine a Russian airstrike on a
hospital has killed a doctor who had
just started working there the attack
tore a gaping hole in the roof and
injured at least five others it was one
of several Russian strikes on Ukraine
and for the second time in two days a
drone targeted Moscow hitting the same
government building damaged the last
time as Crystal gamensing Reports these
drone attacks make Russia's capital
vulnerable and warning some of the
images in her story are graphic
technical issues according to the sign
posted kept people from using the main
entrance to an office tower in moscow's
central business district the issue a
drone strike it's the second drone
strike on this Russian government
building this week
first hit was early Sunday Ukraine has
not taken responsibility and it's not
clear why this particular building is
being targeted
this Russian man likened the hit to a
mosquito biting a human but he also says
nowhere is 100 percent safe in Russia
now Russians had been previously
insulated from the Kremlin so-called
special military operation in Ukraine
until early May that's when the Kremlin
was hit
this man says he's from Donetsk and
dismisses the attacks in Moscow saying
they're nothing compared to the Daily
shelling and deaths in his Ukrainian
hometown
officials in her son shared video from
inside a hospital hit just after 11 A.M
broken glass and blood stains the
Hallmarks of another deadly strike the
World Health Organization noted in May
that it verified more than one thousand
attacks on health care facilities in
Ukraine since the start of the full
invasion the most it has ever recorded
in any humanitarian emergency here a
young doctor was killed and a nurse
among the wounded
it was his first day at work after an
internship says the head of the Hassan
Regional Administration Medical
Department
regime meanwhile is being accused of
terrorist attacks by Russia's defense
spokesperson the claim is that Ukraine
targeted Russian civilian boats in the
Black Sea with unmanned attack vessels
Russia says it destroyed them Ukraine
denies attacking civilian boats
Crystal gemancing Global News London
driving down under next the Australian
setting an ambition anxious and bizarre
world record
[Music]
a frightening moment for the pilot of
that small plane in Quebec City this
morning the Cessna appeared to stall on
takeoff and plunged onto the runway the
pilot the only person on board has only
minor injuries airport authorities say
the plane belonged to a flight training
school NASA says it's back in contact
with the Voyager 2 spacecraft the agency
says it's picked up a heartbeat signal
from the probe Voyager 2 is about 20
billion kilometers from Earth and has
been exploring the universe since 1977.
it stopped receiving commands or sending
data after a wrong command tilted its
antenna two degrees away from Earth it's
hurtling at an estimated 55 000
kilometers through Interstellar space
but NASA says Voyager 2 is still
broadcasting and is in good health
well now to a different kind of mission
a group of mates in Australia took on an
ambitious Underwater Challenge they
converted an old Toyota Land Cruiser
into an EV drove it into the ocean and
cruised along the ocean floor Mike
Armstrong takes a deep dive into how and
why they did it
[Applause]
if it seems like something dreamed up
over drinks well apparently it was to
take a car nicknamed the mud crab and
drive it into the water on one side of
the harbor hoping to come out on the
other the world record we're going for
is the furthest distance driven
underwater by car and the deepest depth
driven underwater by a car now Darwin
Harbor is in the Northern Territory of
Australia it's about seven kilometers
across and at its deepest the bottom is
about 30 meters down at that depth
there's a lot that can go wrong or to
put it another way there's a lot to
ignore this could act like it's another
day in your office and just get the job
done it's really how I'm thinking about
it the rather strange project was part
of a documentary on cult cars in this
case the 1978 Toyota Land Cruiser voila
we're not going to be able to get this
motor driving underwater no roadworthy
and seaworthy are two completely
different things the car's diesel engine
had to be removed and replaced with an
electric motor that new system then had
to be housed in a submarine style
waterproof and oil-filled casing they
spent a lot of time protecting the motor
from water and much less on protecting
the drivers from crocodiles and sharks
I'm pretty sure it brought orange car
coming towards a shark or a crop that
you've seen before I aren't going to be
hanging their hand at all this was
actually the second attempt to cross
Darwin Harbor the first was 40 years ago
and it didn't quite make it they only
got about halfway this is like an urban
myth in Darwin when they did this 40
years ago and I grew up listening to
stories and it almost faded into
mythology well that inspiration brought
together a team of about 30 people and
some technologies they didn't have in
1983. seabed mapping meant they weren't
just driving in the dark although they
did hit some obstacles now the trip was
expected to take 5-7 in hours
mud crab resurfaced two cheering crowds
after about 12 hours they answered the
question could they do it the question
basically left unanswered is still why
Mike Armstrong Global News
that is global national for this Tuesday
I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your Canada
is the sturgeon Moon captured in Calgary
Alberta it happens when the moon is full
during the closest point in its orbit
around Earth and it appears bigger and
brighter than a regular full moon its
visibility Peaks tonight but then at the
end of August there will be a rare blue
super moon two in one month thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you